marry [ __ ] if money is gone what
Marya so you keep a lien marry [ __ ]
that's exactly what it says earth her
marry [ __ ] right [ __ ]
good morning today is Saturday the day
after Katie's birthday so I surprised
him with something that he still doesn't
know about I'll let you know as soon as
we get there so let's let's get out of
the car and let's walk that way because
we're really late not order and then
I'll ask you will Ramon
so what do you think it is you didn't
bother to go eat anything this morning
something like um a bits mood related I
can see why you would think that bring
Jo Jane I'd like all food out here and
it would be
karaoke bar no we're gonna find a hole
in wall art class place they're gonna
draw and paint together
getting closer ha ha ha
this is what we're doing we're gonna
take a pottery class
and I seem like a link you hunted you
told me you wanted to learn
we're gonna ghost it up where are you
trying to put that apron up here and she
told you no time you're waking that's
like I'm a sushi chef now the entire my
hair up anyone it doesn't matter yeah
just whatever wanted to call you
this one's calling me your name is I
can't write into it
I want my piece really classy so the way
with a sponge
you ready I'm ready
her surprising me with the pottery class
was like awesome creating something not
just for myself but alongside with her
and doing it side-by-side with her was
actually pretty awesome cuz it's right
there we didn't really talk that much
but I think it was just a mental focus
and knowing that we're both doing
something simultaneously together and I
thought that was quite romantic we're
finished so did you have fun with it yes
actually I'm trying to think of like
logical things to do it it's like what
if you were using it as a rice for this
part for rice this parts for like the
meats and vegetables and then this
little baby is mine I'm actually really
proud of it turned out okay now we're in
Santa Monica cuz we're in eat Australian
food and then the rest of the day on the
west
that's an Aussie pie try an Aussie pie
and some water that like the only thing
I can say in Australian accent breathing
ah shoot first many non top hot sidekick
our millennial thing to do but even the
establishment is telling us first thing
a picture and we do it I'm at snapchat
get rid of trash gotcha
fly now it's like a hot pocket accessory
give it as a nasty crust that thing guys
you put a croissant flaky like French
pastry on it
I can't compare the two actually though
pockets are like fast food this is like
Thanksgiving in a bundle
like Isaac we don't
you gotta get this on Chios emotes to
just speak one moment if you like
Harry Felton it would be like moments go
ahead of the Australian I swarthy the
Irish accent is actually the easiest
thing out of all access to get fixed
over that you make an accident
lucky charms well you're clearly not
meant to be accents impressionist person
like I don't know I've always so curious
as to how I go high accent season like
are born
giggles Wagga talks like this is it's
busy no you did not Santa Monica
community garden and I've heard of these
Gardens like especially New York has no
people have backyards run yours and
Kimberly garden so then there's like
designated areas in the city where you
can go and run out like your plot of
land and then that's rican garden so I'm
guessing that's what this is and pass me
by I could see that foot cages that we
had on for tomatoes and yes guys thank
you for letting us from the hotel we put
our Cajun upside down we'll be fixing
that soon and this was confirmed it
so you've been enjoying your birthday
Saturday celebration day it's been a
very mellow one that's exactly how I
like it
I intentionally didn't plan a group
dinner for KC this year because every
single year I asked them like so what do
you want to do when you want to go eat
like every year you always tell me
nothing nothing I don't want to do
anything I want to celebrate with anyone
I just want to be with you because I'm
just happy when it's just the two of us
and every year I ignore you and I'm like
whatever you know you want to celebrate
with your friend when your loved one so
I always plan a dinner at least of some
sort
who's this year of the qutilat I'm going
to do it you want
so this year any plan like anything's I
don't know like because of it I feel
kind of like a failure
yeah the whole thing the whole dilemma
when you go on vacation you're you know
how traveling stuff the real vacation
starts when you come back you're resting
the days before you actually go back to
work that's the real vacation that's
exactly how I wanted my profanity like I
want it to be that portion of the
vacation where you're coming back home
you're just resting there's no agenda no
need to rush to get anywhere to see
something or do something no no need for
loudness and like going yeah like I
don't want it I just want it to be like
like the ocean breeze or now you hear
that yeah that sounds like a birthday to
me
well you're too mellow for your own good
cases maybe so since we're here I was
like come on kids we gotta do somethin
dude like can't just be sitting around
doing nothing all day even though he
likes it anyways I convinced him to take
this trapeze class so we're gonna learn
how to do trapeze stuff so I'm excited
yeah are you excited with it yeah for
this for you this is your birthday we're
gonna learn how to be a brain of the bar
learn soon up we go
your six were over dude I love it the
fact that my shoes has the perfect sheet
hey why is it on top of my shoe there we
go the shoes are meant to be dirty
yeah
Oh Joe this Oh beautiful up there I wish
I could do the camera for sure like a
GoPro
oh nice nice [ __ ] it like it yeah
you could have such a blast field here
but again it's a weekend his Danis many
quality time with Daddy but I definitely
want to come back and I want to bring
Isaac so fun
therefore I came with heroin jacket
buddies
I did not come prepared with jacket
hoodie jacket right well we got out of
or we didn't listen
tips are we a gringo restaurant
the chips look like you can get them at
the supermarket that is a clear sign of
green bonus since I'm Chinese
a Chinese food to make an oyster about
the gringo restaurants one in Chinese
would be gone quite low while the quite
a restaurant second I already know
orange chicken beef and broccoli the
people watch on skins Easter but no with
the tip the sweet sour Dib I'm trying to
lean back I got you I know a gringo
restaurants are people working here
like tourist attraction like the biggest
tourist track in LA I know they're here
I'm not gonna be up
good here's a heads up all right - yeah
yeah nice try